hey everybody welcome back to Planet Zoo
in this video I'll be working on a
grizzly bear habitats but before I do
that I want to thank you guys all for
the amazing responses that icon on my
tiger trail video I really wasn't
expecting that but I got so many amazing
comments both really positive and very
critical and I would also like to take a
bit of time here to stress that I am
really happy to get these critical
comments and to get people to tell me
that what I'm doing sucks because
there's no way to improve without at
least being critical yourself and having
other people trying critique your work
as well of course keep it constructive
but please smash me down as much as you
can
verbally naturally because there's no
way that I'm gonna get better at this
game otherwise and especially when it
comes to zoos because at least with how
much I like to take these games
seriously and the fact that being here
with such a following and having people
actually watch my work is quite a
privilege I want to make sure that my
stuff is at least good and maybe even a
bit education or interesting or whatever
it is I do like to approach these games
as a kind of way to nudge into real-life
interests and things like that anyway on
my last video especially on Twitter I
got some really good comments now
I sorry I forgot your name but there was
a specifically good tweet who said that
I needed less climb above trees near the
rockwork of the tiger enclosure which is
totally true the Tigers would
realistically probably be able to escape
although that said I also got a lot of
comments about the in-game functionality
using heat maps that you can check
whether animals can escape or not so
thank you very much about that I use
that to make sure that the Tigers
couldn't escape and thankfully
everything was in order so the tiger
exhibit was pretty much good from an
in-game standpoint when it comes to that
but yeah realism wise could be a bit
better also the staff view was kind of
obscured which is true I'm gonna have to
put more effort into making sure that
while guests might not be able to see
the animals all the time so that the
animals can actually escape from the
guests gaze staff should always be able
to find the animals so that's something
that I'm gonna have to keep
a bit more and also a staff lock of some
sort which is an interesting point and
it's not really part of the game I
suppose I could experiment by adding a
smaller habitat to the end of a staff
flock and then putting a double lock in
there or a double door in there which
for realism purposes would work but in
game it's something that's not really
supported so I'm gonna have to drag the
game a little bit to a different
direction to make that work also I got
the comments about the separation of the
habitat which was lacking and I have to
be honest this is my bad for not
mentioning this during the commentary I
was actually thinking about this I
figured that underneath the bridge would
be a space where the two sides of the
tiger habitat could be split up in case
we get more Tigers or I want to separate
any Tigers because they are pretty
solitary animals and it's something
that's of course really common in an
actual zoo as well so I didn't do it so
far because I didn't really need it but
if need be I think the habitat would
easily be able to be enclosed underneath
the bridge which is a really narrow gap
and on both sides of the bridge are
really enough elements to form a
separate habitat including shelter and
Richmond and all of that yes
so yeah that was just the notes about
the tiger trail and I have to say in
hindsight I'm really happy with the
tiger trail I think it was a really cool
first exhibit to build in the game and I
also have to say this one isn't going to
be quite as good now I'm already really
running behind my time lapse here
because I haven't even talked about what
I've been doing but my idea for this
originally was that I basically had no
idea of what I wanted to do I wanted to
build a glass structure in the game and
then try and make that into some kind of
habitat but there are a bunch of
problems with this for one I wanted to
do it to try and test the in-game glass
pieces now most of the in-game lost
pieces are on the grid which is nice but
not very flexible so I didn't want to
use those so I wanted to use the
off-grid ones and most of those have I'm
not sure how many sides I think six
sides or their triangles
and I tried making geodesic domes out of
those and after a lot of experimentation
I couldn't make it work apparently
somebody has been able to make it work
if you check the Steam Workshop at the
moment you can find the reptile habitats
made by someone whose name is on the tip
of my tongue but yeah they figured out
how to make it work which is really cool
but I couldn't so I ended up going for a
more simple art style shape but still I
realized that this was kind of an issue
because the original idea for this dome
was to make it sort of like a reverse
greenhouse so a habitat where I could
build habitats for animals for which the
climate of the scenario is too warm
because in this scenario it's really hot
it's like nearly 40 degrees Celsius
that's just how the climate of this
scenario works and I had grizzly bears
in my park already who were becoming way
too hot all the time
oh by the way the the reptile house with
the geodesic domes was made by parsley
so shout out to parsley and also they
have a youtube channel which I really
recommend checking out got some really
cool stuff down there I'll link it in
the description but yeah coming back to
the topic of the Bears I wanted to find
a habitat for the Bears to be cool
enough and I figured - well build a
giant building to make an indoor exhibit
and keep it cool enough for the Bears to
stay in but I was halfway through
building this probably about at this
point in the time-lapse when I realized
that this idea was totally bunk because
making a reverse green house is probably
the worst thing for the environment that
you can ever do ironically because you
know keeping a structure cool like this
is basically impossible especially given
that it's all glass and the sun is
shining so altogether that was a very
terrible idea I think the general idea
of creating a large-scale cooler
exhibits in a certain indoor location in
a climate like this scenarios it's
probably not a great idea and
realistically if you want to cool down
your animals in a zoo I should have gone
for a much more subtle and small scale
approach as zoos would do in
your life using sprinklers or water
elements or the common trick of hiding
some kind of cooling system inside rocks
which could also be a heating system but
in general I find rockwork is very often
used to hide things like that related to
regulating temperature I definitely
don't want to build a giant fridge like
I'm doing right now because that's just
going to result in a giant electricity
bill as well so there's that but I still
decided to keep going with it because I
was so far into it and I figured you
know at the end of the day this habitat
is not going to be as realistic and as
thoughtful as the habitat of the Tigers
so honestly a bit disappointed in myself
when it comes to that but at the same
time this is still just the beta this is
still just the time to mess around
experiments in the game and try to
practice with the tools as well so I
figured if nothing else this building
will just be a really nice in-game
practice run to practice building
large-scale glass structures because
that's probably going to be useful later
on when I do build elephant exhibits and
greenhouses and things like that in a
more temperate environment it's a nice
practice also for the more common
enclosure set up where you have emotes
some rock work and fences with paths on
one side and the enclosure on the other
side I know it's not quite as
experimental as the tiger trail but it's
definitely a very common set up in a lot
of zoo so it was a good time to kind of
practice this sort of enclosure setup as
well trying to hide the cliff of the
path and the moats as much as possible
which was something that I was a bit
concerned about I know I tried doing
this during games come for my tiger
temple enclosure as well but I really
didn't have enough time to make it work
in that case so I decided to take my
time here and try to make this
transition work a bit better it's also
nice practice to build a viewing
platform which I hadn't really tried yet
which I'll get into later in this video
and finally I figured I could build
something similar to what Rudy Ren Kamel
did shout out to Rudy who is making lots
of planets ooh content
and I really recommend checking out his
stuff you've probably already seen it
because it's it's really making the
rounds but if you haven't yet check it
out
he made a giant winter dome that was
basically what gave me the idea of maybe
trying something similar I watched his
first video and I skipped to the end of
it at some point and right to the point
where I skipped he said ooh I can feel
you skipping to the end of my video and
I've never been caught off guard on a
YouTube video as much as that so that
was really scary but that aside he puts
out really cool stuff so check him out
alien come down in the description as
well if I don't forget because I'm
really good at forgetting links in the
description so yeah that's my whole
thought process and how I ended up in
this place where I am building an
exhibit that doesn't make as much sense
but I still think it's worthwhile to
keep it and to put out this video I made
it in the end so yeah there you go
also the exterior was really fun to
build the whole class structure I think
was quite successful and I would
definitely love to bring back structures
like this maybe a bit more interesting
and a bit more focused on design instead
of just building a giant archway and
putting gloss in it but it was really
fun to try and mess with the pieces to
try and make this building it's not too
different from things that have tried in
planet coaster but it's been a good
practice to mess around with the glass
pieces the steel pieces and even the art
shapes that we have in game to try and
make something that's almost a little
bit Calatrava ish the tiny bit I'm not a
starchitect my Calatrava is and the zoo
is no major city governing board with
the financial and political power to
afford such starchitect err but you know
it's a similar kind of idea very glossy
modern structure with these exposed
structural elements and just a very
sleek overall look now the exhibit
itself is basically a new place for my
chrisley bears I didn't really explain
this beforehand but
the way that I went about playing the
franchise mode is I first spent a lot of
time just building a zoo focused on
gameplay elements trying to get used to
how to care for the animals how to best
set up habitats and things like that so
that before I went into making scenery
habitats I would already know you know
what the gameplay elements are like what
I need to keep in mind to try and make
them actually work so what I ended up
with was a zoo that worked really well
and made a lot of profits as you can see
in the bottom left corner although of
course this is a this is a non-profit
zoo all of the profits to end up back in
the zoo you know of course but no
basically I I did that so I ended up
with this really kind of ugly but
functional zoo so I wanted to make sure
that at least most of the animals that I
have in there already I can give a
better habitat than they have at the
moment so that's also why I figured I
might as well start off with the grizzly
bears and give them a better place at
this point I was installing some panels
on the glass roof on the Sun side just
to make sure that it weren't beginning
too hot in there it's still a giant
glass building in warm climates but this
should definitely help also brings in
some shade into the interior area on the
size of the bears that is the guests
will still be in the more sunny side but
hopefully that should at least help to
some degree making this a believably
cool building cool in the sense of
temperature of course and at this point
I figured might as well put some
decoration on this building because at
the moment it's a bit too contemporary
and blend so I decided to put a sort of
silhouettes of mountains on it to give
it kind of the idea of North American
landscape of course it still doesn't
really fit into the actual Asian
grassland habitats or environments of
the franchise mode but still I decided
it would be a cool way to spruce up the
exterior of the building a little bit
and then the rest of the scenery overall
is just going to be very simple I put a
giant wall of blah
underneath this section I really wasn't
sure for a while what I would do with
the ground floor whether I would put a
solid wall or something like that there
but I think it helps a lot to just keep
it completely open and you know of
course the building is not completely
open it's mostly closed but to keep the
view of the outside mostly open so a
building feels much larger more open and
less claustrophobic than it really is
and that's basically it
I'm not sure to what extent these trees
would be able to survive in the climate
of this franchise mode but I'm just
going for a bunch of spruces and all
kinds of taiga and tundra temperates
bushes and trees and of course a lot of
rock work you can't forget about the
rock work it's a common staple in zoos
it's a great way to hide again the
barrier on the outside and later on hide
some of the elements like cooling and
things like that
I know geek ISM has already said that
Rock work is easily the most
time-consuming thing when generally
people are building habitats in this
game which i think is totally true it's
something that you tend to just sink a
lot of time into making it look somewhat
natural although there is a weird
balance when it comes to rock work and
making it look natural in a game like
this I think given the fact that the
rocks in the game really do look like
real rocks and realistically if you're
building a zoo you kind of want the rock
work to look like the cements that it
actually is because it's really of
course typically designed to make to
look like natural rock work but it's
really not entirely natural
maybe safe for some large stones and
pebbles and things like that that might
be scattered about but especially when
it comes to rock work that shaped the
walls of
the habitats or cliff sites etc you kind
of have to make it look unnaturally
natural which is a real balance to hit
so I'm not sure exactly how to go and
approach that but so far just putting
rocks down in you know a different kinds
of orders trying to make some formations
with similar rock types but always
placing a different rock and a different
rotation and different kind of
placements every time just helps make it
look a bit more natural and the rest I
suppose goes for the rest of the
habitats as well I'm just putting a lot
of rock work throughout this habitat
again because I can't really do anything
about the ground textures which don't
look too fitting for the kind of habitat
that I'm going for so the rock work is
really going to have to sell the idea of
a North American landscape here and also
just give some fun things to play with
for the animals as well because one of
my favorite things about this game is
still the fact that animals will
interact with everything that you put
inside a habitats so the fact that
everything that you build really feels
so solid is a huge draw for me so
something to keep in mind as well make
their work work at least to some degree
in a shape that animals can climb onto
it and use it to do whatever they want
and aside from that I'm putting a bunch
of other natural elements in here a lot
of dead trees which are cool in real
life because bears like climbing on them
but I have to say maybe I just haven't
seen it happen but as far as I've seen I
haven't seen my bears climb onto the
trees onto the dead trees or logs or
other structures like that so maybe they
don't do it in game although it would be
kind of cool to see something like that
but that was the general idea why I
wanted to put all kinds of big logs and
fallen trees and things like that in the
habitats to give the Bears something to
play with
and then I'm also building a shelter
inside the building here which if I
think about it in hindsight it's a bit
strange I suppose but I figured it would
be the best place to place some bedding
in so it really feels like you're inside
an actual shelter and it helps hide the
view from the guests a little bit as
well so that's why I went with that as
you can see from what I'm building
inside the actual building it's just
featuring a lot of wood trying to go for
a subtle rustic northern American theme
but it's not quite as themed as the
tiger trail is so no specific cultural
references just a lot of woods and logs
and shingles to try and blend in with
the natural foliage as much as I can and
also what you might notice is that I put
a barrier halfway through this building
and I'm leaving the other side empty at
least so far I'll get to that in a few
minutes but the idea for this habitat
was also to split it into in many zoos
in real life you'll find that habitats
of animals you know they can rotate or
separate the animals between different
habitats and that's something that I
wanted to do with the Bears as well here
I had too large of a social group for
the Bears in my old enclosure so I
decided to split them up and I've got
some mothers with some Cubs and then
some men so I'm gonna split up the males
and put them in a different place for
now so that's why I'm leaving one half
of the building empty I'll get to that
side of the habitat as well later on but
yeah it's good for you know the Bears to
keep them playful to maybe rotate them
between different habitats and for
social reasons to separate them
sometimes although then again in real
life zoos you know animals will make
friendships with each other and have all
kinds of social bonds I'm not aware at
this point to what extent the simulation
in planets who goes to that level and
especially in this franchise mode given
that time goes so quickly
animals realistically only live for a
few hours of most
probably not even that so it's gonna be
hard to even as a player create that
sort of social bond with the animals but
at least for the way that I'm laying out
this habitats it's something that I
wanted to keep in mind and again this is
all under the guise that this building
indoors would have been cooled or
something like that I know it's not a
very realistic thing but in this case
I'm going to imagine that it's some sort
of a reverse greenhouse where there's
more of an actual mountain like North
American climate inside of this building
and compared to the very warm Asian
continent climates on the outside so
yeah here's another building inside a
building to give this whole structure a
bit more charm because the entire modern
look of the building is not as nice and
not as much like an actual natural
habitats so I'm trying to cover that up
as much as I can with more rustic
architecture and lots of trees and
bushes and rook work of course can't
forget about the rock work so that's
basically what I'm doing at this point
it's also again a good practice to try
out some of the other foliage because I
do want to make use of the beta as much
as I can to get used to all the
different themes and scenery pieces in
the game because there will be more in
the final game and hopefully if I know
all of the pieces from the beta by
hearts and I used them it's going to be
easier to adjust to all of the new
pieces once we get the full game so
hopefully it'll be easier to just
altogether start building habitats and
creating scenes in the full game as well
so yeah it's just good practice which I
think in the end is always a good
message to keep in mind even if you're
not happy with something like I'm not
happy with this habitat because it's not
really realistic at the end of the day
it's still really good practice and I'm
really happy with the exterior shell of
the building and some of the path
elements like this fencing and the
smaller foliage around it and altogether
it's just good to try and build stuff
even if you're not happy with it it only
means that the things you build after it
or it can be better which I know it's
common sense but I just wanted to put it
out there even if just to I don't know
make myself a bit happier about this
build in general I mean I don't hate it
but it's it's definitely not as good as
I would have liked it to be and next
time I do a grizzly bear habitat I would
love to make it more spread out and try
and incorporate the guests in a bit more
of a yeah a more novel way because this
is a very very traditional you know you
just you just stand somewhere as a guest
and the Bears are somewhere on the other
side of some sort of cliff I think there
are much more interesting ways to try
and also get animal and guest
interaction so yeah also something that
I should keep in mind that I should at
least talk about right now so you guys
know I'm aware of it I do and I'm keepin
mind holding spaces and kitchens and
vents and things like that which
realistically would be attached to
actual habitats you know you need to
find out a system of where the staff
gets in and how the animals can get in
and out of the habitats and have their
own sort of locked off space where the
guests can see them for all kinds of
purposes so that's something that I do
want to keep in mind just for now I'm
focusing on the habitats themselves but
realistically if I wanted to take this
habitat to the next level
I could have attached a building on the
side of this building and have a have a
holding space for the Bears in there
there's enough space for it and I did
put some facilities that in game I need
like water management and electricity
but I didn't really delve into it so far
but it's something that I would like to
go into a bit more in the final game
just because personally I like focusing
on realism like that because it's you
know even though it's just a game and
it's just a fantasy the fact that if
details like that are worked out it all
feels a little bit more like it could be
real which is something that I like to
go for in the end so yeah also as you
might have noticed there's no waterfall
in any of these enclosures maybe I
should have done that maybe
being a terrible youtuber I've noticed
that every youtuber seems to not be able
to resist ending a waterfall into every
habitat so sorry I messed up on that one
I decided it wasn't too necessary I have
a lot of water around anyway but yeah
should definitely have some more
waterfalls although that's a bit sassy
but I can't really fault anyone for
ending them because after playing planet
coaster waterfall lists for so long it's
really cool to see this game have really
beautiful waterfalls so I would love to
make use of it as much as possible as
well anyway that is just about it for
this habitat I'm getting ready to put
some of the last foliage in and then
I'll get one of the male bears and put
them into this habitats maybe also get
the other one later but I'm just gonna
see you know how the Bears actually
respond to being put in a different
habitat because I haven't tried making a
completely split off habitat in the game
yet but yeah this is basically what it
looks like in the end I made some minor
changes also when I wasn't recording
anymore like I made the horizontal beam
there gray to make it fit in a bit more
with the glass and so the white arch of
the top of the building comes out a bit
better but yeah as you can see this is
what it looks like from the inside it
kind of have that little mini biome a
little mini mountainous forest region
inside the actual grassland biome of the
franchise and I think it works out
decently as long as you don't look too
much of the ground textures because it's
it's far more red orangish than I would
have liked it to be realistically but
that's something I can't really do
anything about anyway that's it for this
episode I'd like to thank you guys for
watching and I hope to you in the next
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you